la semaine dernière à enquête tout ce
qui voulait c'était un bon défi pour lui
là
[Musique]
portez plainte
Bob c'est Robert
cette femme a été entendue dès le
lendemain nous révélations fracassante
sur Robert Miller d'autres femmes ont
reconnu le milliardaire québécois qui
pendant une douzaine d'années jusqu'en
2006 payait des adolescentes pour avoir
des relations sexuelles
[Musique]
deux autres femmes témoignent de leur
expérience avec Robert Miller j'avais
les dents crush puis des Extel genre de
choses que ils pouvaient nous aider qui
pourrait m'en payer
fixer super attrayant pour une jeune
fille de mon âge est-ce qui t'a payé des
broches non
non
je parlais de mon école secondaire et
quand j'ai accepté les parts de souliers
c'était une façon pour moi de conclure
un accord plus que comme d'être assis là
parlé à la fin c'est comme j'acceptais
ce qui allait s'en venir ici Marie Maude
Denis bienvenue à enquête
[Musique]
j'essaie de retrouver cette maison là
plusieurs fois comme au fil des années
quand je passais à Westmark
quand j'avais
tombé sur cette maison là j'ai retombé
cette maison là puis là la première fois
que je la revois depuis 2007 donc c'est
assez simple
[Musique]
je m'appelle Julie en 2006 2007 quand
j'avais 16-17 ans j'ai fait la rencontre
de Robert Miller
je travaillais comme tout étudiant pas
mal avec un emploi
chez Sears j'étais dans les départements
des catalogues et entrer le site à temps
partiel dans le même département que moi
[Musique]
et puis on a travaillé les deux ensemble
on sait des liens oui collègue de
travail mais c'était une femme qui était
un petit peu plus âgée que moi qui avait
une voiture qui avait beaucoup de bijoux
elle portait beaucoup beaucoup de bijoux
et apporter beaucoup de sac à main de
designer aussi donc c'est sûr que ça te
tient une curiosité d'une personne que
moi crée un salaire minimum
de voir elle qui a quand même une
certaine opulence
puis qui avait cette liberté là que moi
je n'avais pas encore
puisqu'elle travaillait au catalogue
comme moi
j'étais persuadé qu'elle avait qu'elle
avait qu'elle avait un autre emploi qui
avait quelque chose d'autre faisait en
sorte que elle pouvait se permettre tout
ça
elle est devenue comme une grande sœur
pour moi
je me suis confiée à elle j'ai développé
un lien de confiance assez solide avec
elle elle a dû déceler
que j'aime mon estime personnel était
pratiquement inexistante que je me
cherchais que j'avais une soif de
liberté d'en faire plus
j'étais une personne qui était quand
même qui avait quand même un caractère
aussi donc elle a pu voir ça au fil des
mois parce que ça a vraiment duré
pendant plusieurs mois puis un certain
moment donné c'est venu sur le fait que
un de ses emplois un de ces autres
emplois c'était quel état assistante
personnelle d'une personne
d'un businessman très accompli très
occupé puis qu'elle dans le fond c'était
pas compliqué ben s'occupait de gérer
son calendrier ses rendez-vous puis
c'était pas plus compliqué que ça que le
moins je trouvais ça très très cool
alors que j'avais avec mon sentiment de
liberté de se désire là de liberté de
pouvoir sortir de pouvoir
exploser encore plus comment je dirais
ben moi ça a renforcé mon mon envie de
travailler pour un homme comme ça
pas beaucoup de sous moi à l'époque
l'argent est comme devenu un attrait
puis j'ai accepté
on se faisait que c'était pas long c'est
qui qui était gentil c'est que on allait
avoir beaucoup de sous je réalisais pas
dans quoi je m'embarquais en disant oui
c'était juste comme de toute peut-être
un peu quand j'étais jeune comme
pas inconsciente le insouciante quand tu
étais jeune mais avec quel âge c'était
proche de ma fête de 15 ans je me
souviens je suis pas certaine si je suis
allée avant ou après mais tu sais que
d'avoir 14 ans c'était comme positif
aussi
de ce que j'avais compris c'est que on
pouvait aller le voir juste pour parler
c'est mais quand tu es là-bas tu te
rends compte que c'est pas juste il y a
un certain moment donné ben ça a encore
eu un shift puis elle me dit comme je
lui ai parlé j'ai parlé à Bob de toi je
lui ai montré des photos de toi il
serait il préfère la place dans son
horaire très très bref préfère la place
dans son horaire pour te rencontrer
privilégié de pouvoir exactement j'étais
privilégiée qu'il aille accordé du temps
à
regardez les photos de moi mais aussi à
faire du temps dans son horaire
excessivement chargé pour me rencontrer
[Musique]
quand on est arrivé devant la maison on
est rentré dans dans l'allée ils
attendaient dehors pour nous accueillir
super souriant super charismatique comme
s'il avait fait ça depuis des années
puis il m'a automatiquement mis à l'aise
ce que je me rappelle de lui c'est son
sourire qui était absolument comme
étincelant il avait un teint fait que je
me disais que c'est quelqu'un qui
voyageait qui a en flirt en Floride le
kiki qui était un teint relativement
bronzé puis il y avait les cheveux
teints
j'ai envie de dire qu'il y avait 63 ans
62 64 mais paraissait comme un essayer
de paraître comme un homme de 54 55 ans
environ
[Musique]
décris nous ta première fois
ici en fait à l'hôtel Reine Elizabeth
je me souviens parce que j'étais super
impressionné du lieu c'était gros
c'était à Montréal en rentrant dans la
chambre de avec Bob parce que fallait
l'appeler Bob et on allait s'asseoir
comme au divin puis le serveur nous
demander ce qu'on voulait boire il y
avait de l'alcool j'ai souvent c'était
comme doux dans le sens que tu parlais
pas très fort
c'était lentement
il posait des questions sur notre âge
qu'est-ce qu'on faisait comment ça
allait à la maison
tu posais des questions même sur nos
parents tu nous demandait de quoi on
rêvait
dis-moi à l'époque j'avais les dents
crush puis j'avais pas maman elle avait
pas les moyens on n'avait pas beaucoup
de souffle et qu'elle avait pas les
moyens de me payer des brushes puis il
disait que c'était le genre de choses
que il pouvait nous aider qui pourrait
m'en payer
super attrayant pour une jeune fille de
mon âge
est-ce que tu as payé des broches non
non
c'était de la manipulation c'était pour
apprendre à mieux nous connaître pour
mieux nous utiliser il semblait très
intéressant sur ma vie où est-ce que
j'en étais dans ma vie mais
futurs projets
par exemple des exemples qui me
demandaient c'est après mon ma
graduation l'après mon que je graduis
les Kos secondaire que les étaient mes
plans pour les études que j'avais parlé
que j'allais dans un en gestion
hôtelière puis que j'ai très excité
parce que j'avais une passion pour les
voyages et puis lui enchaîné de façon
très très mielleuse mais très calme
c'est très calculé mais tellement smooth
comme qu'est-ce que tu dirais dans
l'étudier en Europe c'est qu'est-ce que
tu dirais de pousser plus loin tes rêves
c'est comme vous puis que ça serait ça
ça serait possible pour toi Europe ou tu
sais je pensais à la Floride
et pourvu je pensais pas aussi loin que
ça j'étais très contente avec les choix
que j'avais fait qui était à ma portée
je suis entendu c'est qu'il pourrait
t'aider à atteindre ses buts exactement
le fait que tes parents n'aient pas
beaucoup de sous
ça a joué dans la façon dont il
composait avec toi pour moi oui
pour moi oui puis
parce que tu es souvent quand j'étais
plus jeune que les amis les parents
donnent une petite allocation le disque
15 20 dollars moi c'est des fois j'en
avais pas faites le fait d'aller le voir
mais j'en avais de l'argent après pour
faire des petites sorties ou des acheter
des vêtements plus de marques ou des
choses comme ça fait que moi oui ça a
été un
argument qui a fonctionné et c'est très
clair il savait quel âge tu avais mais
oui
il savait que j'étais au secondaire
j'y avais dit que j'étais bonne à
l'école il m'a demandé si je commence à
aller à l'école quand je leur voyais
est-ce que ça va être ton âge précis
j'ai jamais dit en passant j'ai 17 ans
c'était vraiment sous-entendu puis la
façon que je parlais de mon école
secondaire et puis
de que j'allais aller au cégep ben c'est
comme très sous-entendu de mon ange puis
un certain moment donné
vers la fin de la conversation il m'a
demandé quelle pointure de soulier je
portais et que là je lui ai donné ma
pointure il me dit attends un instant je
reviens donc il est parti pour revenir
avec quatre paires de souliers c'est
paresseux c'est des pères de marque qui
dans le temps était des marques qu'avec
mon salaire chez se je pouvais pas me
permettre
mais il t'a dit explicitement la
prochaine fois qu'on se voit ça va être
pour une relation sexuelle voici comment
ça va se dérouler et oui la prochaine
fois qu'on va se voir ça va on va on va
on va être
il va avoir on va aller plus loin là on
va aller plus loin puis c'est pour ça
que je te dis ça que moi je suis très
propre de ma personne que je me fais
tester fixé sans condom mais encore une
fois c'était vraiment dans de la
légèreté vraiment vraiment dans la
légèreté parce que les bois de souliers
sont arrivés vers la fin donc moi je
sens aussi que quand j'ai accepté les
parts de souliers c'était une façon pour
moi de conclure un accord plus que comme
d'être assis là parlé à la fin c'est
comme j'ai accepté
ce qui allait s'en venir leur expérience
avec Robert Miller a eu un effet durable
et pas du tout agréable dans leur vie au
retour la suite du témoignage des deux
jeunes femmes
beaucoup de consommation d'alcool
puis d'autres consommations j'ai essayé
plein de drogues
[Musique]
les deux femmes que vous avez entendues
ont en commun d'avoir rencontré Robert
Miller alors qu'ils étaient mineurs mais
leur histoire ne se déroule pas de la
même façon voyons voir ce qui est arrivé
à Julie après avoir accepté les belles
paires de souliers neufs du milliardaire
un cadeau pas du tout désintéressé
mes amis ont une réaction à laquelle je
m'attendais pas donc très négative très
surprise
ils m'ont dit que c'était pas normal
que ça ça a été mon premier cue que je
me suis à quelque chose de quelque chose
que je comprends pas
[Musique]
mes deux parents ça a été un événement
qui a été
très très difficile puis je m'en veux
mais
je savais pas mieux à cette époque là
puis
mes parents ont pris en charge de
prendre les
mes parents pris en charge de prendre
les boîtes de souliers donc mes parents
se sont présentés avec les bords de
souliers et puis lui ont remis ils ont
pas fait des scènes c'était pas la place
pour faire ça du tout
mais
tu savais que tu étais très saisie là
[Musique]
c'est avant de monter à la Chambre des
fois j'allais au petit bord en bas
clairement j'avais pas l'air d'avoir
l'âge personne n'a jamais posé de
questions une fois j'étais arrivé en
voiture
je sais pas pourquoi que on était arrivé
par là ça devait être un taxi qui était
rentré par le stationnement je me
souviens pas mais le parti le portier
nous avait nommé il y a du vent j'étais
avec une amie que Bob venait d'arriver
ça faisait pas longtemps
donc vous étiez deux adolescentes qui
sortirent un taxi et vous avez pas eu
besoin de demander
rien qu'est-ce que tu penses qui se
passait dans l'hôtel en terme de
connaissances de ce qui se passait ici
ben il devait avoir constaté qu'il y
avait beaucoup de jeunes filles puis que
c'était monsieur là parce que il nous
avait donné son son nom puis c'est quand
qu'il nous a vu c'est le lien qui avait
fait et il y avait été il y avait été
stationné sa voiture je sais pas
quelques minutes une heure avant il
savait et le nom qui vous a donné c'est
Bob c'est Bob ouais puis pour revenir le
voir il fallait que tu avais une
quelqu'un
comment ça se passe c'est ça
comment aborder les jeunes filles ben
avec l'argent ce qu'on se payait ça en
était venu que ça se parlait moi je
pense à l'école parce que des fois il y
a des filles que je connaissais pas qui
venaient me voir pour me dire ben moi
aussi je veux ça
demander des vierges des personnes
vierges et te demander à toi il me l'a
demandé aussi ouais une de ces défenses
c'est-à-dire que qu'il était impuissant
depuis plus de 20 ans est-ce que c'est
ce que tu as constaté toi
non mais
c'était pas l'homme le plus vigoureux je
dirais mais tu éjaculer quel effet ça a
eu sur le reste de ta vie les premières
années d'abord
les premières années j'ai été longtemps
dans une relation de violence conjugales
parce que
me considérait comme pas dit
je dirais je le sais
l'autre contrôler ça a été aussi je
pense un peu ma relation avec l'argent
je dirais que tu Gégé l'argent ça
m'écœure encore
pourquoi je sais pas j'ai l'impression
que
je sais pas que tu peux acheter des
choses que tu devrais pas je sais pas
c'est ça peut blesser ça peut détruire
ça peut
acheter le silence
est-ce que tu veux nous parler de
quelques années
beaucoup de consommation d'alcool
puis d'autres consommations j'ai essayé
plein de drogues
j'étais dans le milieu des bords un peu
j'étais encore mineur
dans la ville puis j'ai pu me sortir de
ça quand je suis devenue mère
en fait tu as eu un garçon ouais
j'ai l'impression que
j'aurais eu trop peur je suis pas sûr
que j'aurais été une bonne mère pour une
fille pourquoi pas
avec mes blessures la peur qu'avec des
choses comme ça
qu'à se mettre en danger
comment tu t'es senti quand tu as lu qui
avait mis toute cette histoire
ça le probablement dû me motiver à
parler de mon histoire ça m'a mis
vraiment en colère
il y avait l'air la façon la façon que
ça a été écrit c'est comme si il est
indigné
comme comment osez-vous comment
foutaise balive tout ce que tu veux là
à être en colère
que ça ressorte comme c'est pas vrai ce
qui s'est passé qu'avec le nombre de
personnes qui ont souffert de ça ou qui
souffrent encore aujourd'hui de ça je
moi c'est monstrueux pour moi
quand tu as vu le reportage qu'est-ce
que tu as vu j'ai vu
que je ressentais aussi de la honte j'ai
vu qu'on avait été
manipulé
j'ai réalisé que même si je pensais m'en
mettre sorti ça avait probablement
affecté ma vie plus que je pensais aussi
puis je me suis mis à me questionner à
savoir mais on est combien
quand MiTo est arrivé quand epstin est
arrivé
à chaque nouvelle personne à chaque
meeto à chaque dénonciation j'allais
voir sur google si il sortait
c'est quoi sur terre l'histoire de
Robert
je l'attendais à ce moment
[Musique]
et là la dernière étape ça s'en vient
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire en sortant en
sortant d'ici je m'en vais au poste de
police pour porter plainte
vont suivre puis j'espère que même les
filles que j'ai pu influencer là dedans
vont vouloir le faire je pense que
ensemble on aurait pu faire devant tout
ça
après la pause d'autres détails de cette
enquête avec nos journalistes Brigitte
Noël et Pascal Turbide
[Musique]
quelques compléments d'information avec
mes collègues qui ont mené cette enquête
bonjour Brigitte Noël Pascal surbile
alors Brigitte d'abord ce qu'on veut
savoir si Robert Miller comment il
réagit à ces deux nouveautés
les alliations c'est un relationnel qui
a répondu à nos questions cette fois
pour nous dire que toutes ces nouvelles
histoires étaient motivées par l'appât
du gain parce que nous avions révélé la
fortune importante de Monsieur Miller et
donc les femmes qui s'ajoutaient à notre
liste de témoins le faisait pour pour
son argent et Pascal de votre côté vous
avez posé des questions à l'hôtel Reine
Élisabeth effectivement et on a aucune
information à nous donner le directeur
général indique qu'il ne sait pas du
tout ce qui s'est passé à cette époque
là bon c'est deux nouveaux témoignages
Brigitte ils sont arrivés là tout juste
après la diffusion de notre reportage la
semaine dernière oui d'ailleurs Julie
qui témoigne aujourd'hui reconnu Robert
Miller grâce à notre portage on sait que
Miller et plusieurs heures dans son
entourage utilisaient de construisait de
fausses histoires pour les femmes qui le
rencontrait et donc il y a des victimes
et des témoins comme Julie qui qui ont
finalement su à qui ils avaient eu à
faire il y a toutes ces années mais
Pascal il y en a d'autres comme
Geneviève que vous avez interviewé qui
savait très bien qui était Robert elle
le savait en fait depuis 2010 elle avait
vu un reportage dans le Journal de
Montréal avec sa photo et c'est à ce
moment-là qu'elle l'avait reconnu et
elle nous a dit si j'avais su à ce
moment-là qu'il y avait une enquête de
police j'y serai allé il a fallu qu'elle
attende 12 ans pour se présenter au
poste de police comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage donc elle est allée voir la
police de Montréal comment ça s'est
passé ça s'est bien passé parce que dans
le fond elle s'est fait dire que le but
de la démarche n'était pas de les
accuser elle-même de proxénétisme même
si elles avaient recruté des jeunes
filles powerpart Miller lorsqu'elles
étaient jeunes le but de la démarche
était de porter plainte contre Robert
Miller ça leur a fait beaucoup de bien
le discours a changé on se souvient la
semaine dernière dans votre reportage
certaines avaient témoigné en 2009 avoir
eu expérience négatives lors de cette
première enquête de police qui peut
abouti sur des accusations Brigitte
parallèlement à l'enquête de police on
sait pas si officiellement à lire
ouverte mais ça bouge chez futur
l'entreprise de Robert Miller oui donc
quelques heures seulement après la
diffusion de notre partage on a lancé
que Robert Miller avait démissionné à
ses fonctions de PDG de l'entreprise il
dit quitté pour se concentrer sur sa
santé et pour les recours judiciaires
qui comptent entreprendre contre
Radio-Canada
l'entreprise a également annoncé qu'il
n'était plus le président du conseil
d'administration de future le registre
des entreprises nous révèle cependant
qu'il demeure le propriétaire de sa
compagnie l'entreprise également annoncé
qu'elle coupait les ponts avec tous les
individus nommés d'entre dans notre
reportage qui avait des liens avec
Youtube donc certains employés et
notamment le National Criminal
Investigation service qui était l'agence
de sécurité privée exactement qui
travaille souvent pour Monsieur Milo qui
avait son local à même l'édifice de
futur électronique ça point clair donc
YouTube va couper les liens avec cette
entité parce qu'elle a un dernier mot
sur la démarche des jeunes filles qui
témoignent dans votre enquête conjointe
Robert Miller dit qu'elles sont
maintenant motivées par la peau du gain
c'est quoi votre expérience là vous qui
leur avait parlé nous on a aucun indice
qui nous mène à penser que ces jeunes
filles là nous ont contacté par à cause
de la patte du gain ou parce qu'elle
savait que Robert Miller était un homme
riche et nous ont contacté de façon
indépendante avec des détails que elle
seule connaisse et des détails qu'on a
coloré en autant qu'on le sache c'est du
solide et aussi c'est motivé surtout par
le désir de enfin donner la vérité dire
la vérité c'est beaucoup ce qu'on sent
chez les filles qui nous ont contactés
et si je peux ajouter dans le code Julie
elle avait déjà publié son témoignage
sur un autre site Web en 2018 donc on
avait la preuve que qu'elle l'avait
exprimé ce témoignage bien avant le
reportage merci beaucoup de votre
excellent travail merci merci
j'espère que vous avez apprécié les
reportages de ce soir au nom de toute
l'équipe merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
je vous donne rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine pour une autre langue
[Musique]